Guys,
I'm gonna Shit my pants.
Why I ate so much cheese shit bro.
Now we have a toilet.
It's water little bit and it was wonderful.
The thing confused me man.
One shoot the water but I can I that you can do both.
Whatever you want.
If you shoot it up there before it'll make you shit harder to like shoot.
Probably it's a primer and heal.
The problem with that is when you take one of those shits when you've got just
shit all over your ass and spray something on,
it gets messy.
Shit goes everywhere.
So why did you want to do the quarterly call the lady.
Come on Bro.
That's beautiful.
Wow.
I'm talking to him.
What's your out by the lake?
No,
it's quite large.
Instead they're like,
no dude,
I'm telling you it's gorgeous.
Big Bear.
Big restaurants does less white trash up there.
The families get the other people I've been going to hate me for it.
They hate when I bring it up cause I get so fucking sacred like well they don't
want it to be like Nas.
Kanye West.
How's it a secret of Kanye West says ski town or what?
What is it going to be on your podcast?
What's happening on man?
What's hard?
Is that happening?
No,
it'd be,
it'll probably happen.
It's just Kanye is,
you know,
he's a complicated artist and I'm sure there's a bunch of other issues.
First of all,
he wants to get to know me.
We've got to get to hang out together and,
oh,
steam shovel Felder.
We'll time that shit.
We'll do it dude.
Just come on around that time.
Show.
Fuck it.
We'll do it.
Do bring him to his classroom.
He's a really nice guy,
man.
When I talked to him on the phone,
he's a very,
very nice guy.
You already talked to him?
Yeah,
I talked to on friends,
so nice guy
will do it,
but I'm not in a rush,
you know?
Hey,
I told you guys I really liked doing these as much as I like doing anything.
Like when someone says like,
what's a,
what's your favorite guest or is there one guest you've never had on just this,
it doesn't exist.
They don't exist.
There's no one I like.
I like doing podcasts.
I like doing podcasts with everyone,
watching fights.
Dude call a future that that guy who's working on longevity drugs.
That was fascinating.
Yeah.